if you say democracy to a Russian person
we've never had democracy the first
mention historically of Russia is 882
there's never been a single democratic
transition of power ever ever yeah the
only time Russia experimented with quote
unquote democracy was the period between
1991 and 1999 When Vladimir Putin
becomes prime minister and eventually
president that period is probably one of
the most traumatic periods in the
history of anyone alive in Russia today
it was a time in which you went from a
poor and unfree society which was the
Soviet Union to a society of complete
chaos rampant crime you were a
university Professor with a respectable
job today and tomorrow and I mean
tomorrow you were selling your
belongings in the street your children
who were in school and doing well
suddenly your son was shipped off to
fight in Chia which you'd never heard of
before and your daughter was a
prostitute